Hollywood guy candy with the minimizing
shop it's a good-looking cast all around
it's a little awkward when you stand
next to them and let me just tell you
something this crew is competitive on
the screen and also off which one of you
guys goes harvest energy Wayne goes
really hard-hearted and Jason Statham
actually in no uncertain terms whatever
in his entire life go harder than me in
the gym my god no I got him he's
handsome pretty boy stuff you know diva
stuff without a shadow of a doubt it's
Jason Statham probably me because my
head is bigger than his and
circumference wise it covers a lot of
ground so it's shinier but also it just
means I have a bigger brain I'm what you
call a nice cold can of whoop-ass yeah
his hands are like lethal very very fast
because your description is deadly you
guys the bigger size definitely Twain
pull the curtain back swing is a real
softy like saying please I could tell
you that I have layers of emotion that's
why Statham is Jesse's angry that's the
problem
[Music]